there is the argument that my data is my
own and when I do something on facebook
or on okcupid or wherever that that is
an asset that I've created that I
deserve to control right of course
Facebook's argument and obviously okay
keep his argument as well what we're
giving you in exchange for your data
very clearly is these are these tools
like you you on okay he but you can find
dates on facebook you can connect with
long-lost friends you have an ez
platform to collect pictures you thought
you know to the extent that any of these
sites are useful that's why people use
them there's nobody that has to use
Facebook or certainly okcupid there's
plenty of alternatives for that people
have argued that you should be able to
get money in exchange for contributing
your data to Facebook a Facebook goes
and sells the fact that you're into
Ferraris or whatever to Ferrari and so
then you're there for you see ads and
are somehow incrementally more likely to
buy our nice car that you should somehow
get money from that but my argument
there is that your what they're giving
you in exchange for this information is
the fact that you can use Facebook for
free you know it's not like a phone
service where i used to have like a
fifty-dollar phone bill or a hundred
phone bill every month you know it's
free however I think there's a good
argument for you being able to read when
you're tired of that exchange I don't
want to use facebook anymore you should
be able to exit that experience holy
rather than leaving whatever vestige of
yourself you have to leave now I know
that they give you tools for that in the
world I think generally is coming around
to this idea but it is scary even to me
as an owner one of these websites you're
going to sit there and live online and
for whatever reason you want to break up
with the site that you're still beholdin
to them even after you've made that
decision privacy historically has been a
luxury of the rich in certain ways like
I think I bring up these examples in the
book but you know it you want to have a
private car in a train you want to have
a house with walls or a house with a big
yard and walls you want to live in some
remote stretch out in Woodstock or
wherever you know there's not jobs up
there and out in Montana with these huge
branches and stuff you know unless you
happen to be running a ranch so like
private islands all this stuff these are
all extremely expensive private jets
extremely expensive options that the
people who have a lot of money choose to
take somewhat for privacy some of our
convenience but for the Internet I mean
it's hard to argue that it will be you
your head to remain offline right so
it's that means it's probably going to
be harder and to the extent that people
who have less money have less time to
spend worrying about this kind of stuff
the same way that that obviously well
through people tend to worry a lot more
about what they're eating kale and all
this other stuff to make the analogy to
the online world it probably will be the
case if you with more leisure people
with more time to be educated about it
will probably have a more private online
experience I'm not sure it's the money
itself that will drive that I don't
think you're going to have to give
Facebook a hundred dollars or whatever
it is to keep private although it might
come to that I think I think people who
have more money will be able to live a
more private life online